bootleg hit podcast special guests in
here representing sack man he got his
new album out [__] talk over wrapped
over rap should talk over not greater
than not greater than right we should
talk over rap
he does some [__] talking TV about the
bags here welcome sir what's up bro how
you feeling congrats on the album man
appreciate that [__] bro for sure
um yeah we gotta run back and interview
but my time for trades are terrible
because we do need to sit down and do a
real real chat no but real quick so you
got Skillet baby on the album Skillet
baby I got my brother K Flex I gotta
player Posse Stacks you feel I'm Skillet
baby more like the more a stab the only
established artist I got on there
um real quick before we have you do some
[__] talking
um how have you been able to I feel like
you're one of the few artists from Sac
that I've noticed is really trying to
like move on some positive [__] and not
really necessarily be
um wrapped up in some of the more
negative sides of you know what we know
Sacramento for sure for sure is that
something that you feel like has helped
you a lot uh yeah definitely definitely
it's for sure helped me a lot like even
when it comes to getting booked features
like you feel me birthday parties like
yeah for sure like yeah to use like the
parents except the youth [__] with my
music and [__] so that that's definitely
a plus in this [__] for sure uh are you
guys lighting the beam again this next
season with the Kings there forever yeah
it's there forever yeah it's not yeah
I'm not gonna go nowhere the beam is
never going anywhere yeah we ain't heard
about it like only being there for a
season so it should be there yeah there
it is well look bro I appreciate you
you're obviously if y'all ain't no
tapping with this kid he's one of the
hottest West Coast artists period right
now appreciate that who album is out and
let's let him talk his [__] come on
oh
all right
[Music]
this [__] sick when they [__] around and
change on you knowing you the one that
really bust your [__] brain form I'm
just jumping in this bag switching lanes
on them knowing I'm a [__] put by the
bag on that name for them for all the
real [__] that I did this when I get
back [__] we are not the same this [__]
A mismatch I'm the type of [__] throw a
bone [__] knick knack and if you crying
about the [__] take the [__] back I
see you gonna drop a tape man that [__]
whack is hard to stand on the [__] you
rap cause you don't spit facts all I
talk is Cash [__] you must hate Stacks
I'll show a hundred thousand cash [__]
all racks that's all facts [__] No Cap
I didn't iced out my whole neck [__]
off rap I see you with that diamond does
chain take that [__] back I ain't really
[__] with no snakes I got Ace for
that you don't see me [__] with that
Gucci I need new Casa you kicking with
them broke [__] you need new partners
I just add another piece of shrooming
scene Chewbacca started geeking in the
club and I still knocked her
oh
off the shroom scene
two damn it
yo [__] hey
uh deep about the bag in the building
that was hard brother I appreciate you
pulling up man go get the album for
having me man [__] talk over rap out now
go grab it man all platforms Apple
Spotify go subscribe to my YouTube is
there a tour happening yep I'm throwing
a tour for my birthday my uh the body
back celebration tour starting October
all right so go see him I'm sure you're
gonna be all over the West Coast yeah
we're pulling up everywhere man linking
my bio linking any social media bio if
you got it click that link it's right
there there it is boom I appreciate you
guys watching this freestyle we got
another one coming and then another one
and then another one and they're all
brought to you by our good Folks at LRG
clothing you already know what it is LRG
been keeping you fly for years they got
so much new fly gear right now
l-r-g.com promo code bootleg when you
check out you'll save 30 off
l-r-g.com another freestyle is on the
way presented by LRG